le pays faisait partie de ceux dont la
pandémie n'avait pas trop perturber le
quotidien
mais aujourd'hui la suède est inquiète
touché par un variant angles est plus
dévastateur le pays a enregistré 5371
nouvelles contaminations ce mercredi un
chiffre qui peut sembler dérisoire vu de
france mais qui représente une hausse
considérable pour la suède et ses 10
millions d'habitants
le variant britannique se propage très
rapidement il sera très probablement la
souche dominante d'ici quelques semaines
afin d'éviter de nouveaux décès le
gouvernement suédois a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures ce mercredi en plus de
l'interdiction de la vente d'alcool
après 20 heures à compter du 1er mars
les restaurants bars et cafés fermeront
leurs portes à 20h30
le nombre de personnes réunies dans l'e
commerce sera lui limité dans les
régions les plus peuplées du pays le
port du masque sera quant à lui
recommandé dans les commerces transports
et lieu de travail
des mesures qui ont pour objectif
d'éviter une troisième vague épidémique
tout en gardant une vie presque normale
moins de treize mille décès imputés aux
qu'ovide 19 ont été enregistrés sur le
territoire suédois depuis le début de
l'épidémie